hey guys how's it going so today we're
going to be unboxing the pokemon gold
plus now I'm pretty excited about this I
was a lot more excited about this until
the Apple Keynote and they announced
there will be a companion app for the
Apple watch for Pokemon go plus and
there will be so many more features in
that then this can ever really handle
although I have absolutely no idea what
this is going to be like because I
haven't tried it I've only read a few
reviews and I don't like to take the
reviews for face value but sometimes
they were usually true either way I've
been having so much fun playing pokemon
go with my friends I don't play it as
much as I did before but I'm patiently
not patiently waiting for some new
pokemon to be out so that I can try to
catch them all I still haven't caught
all of the US ones but it's it's a
struggle out there guys it's a real
struggle let's open up this and see what
we see what we've got
don't cut towards yourself after tell
myself that every time I pick up a knife
I feel like a lot of people will end up
getting this who don't have an Apple
watch or who are on Android phones
first things first we've got directions
I need a screwdriver you can wear it on
your pocket you can wear it on your belt
you can wear it as a watch I'm going to
set these directions aside because of a
feeling I might actually need those whoo
so we've got the wristband option and
we've got the little I'm not sure what
they're calling it I'm going to call it
a nugget so we've got our little nugget
right here
looks good it looks like the battery is
already installed remove and discard
before use here's our band
[Music]
so assuming he just pops right in there
oh so here's what you do so you just
take off this back screw and then you
screw it to this I feel like that
could've been easier maybe it's
childproof do we have like a first step
what's our first step
open the configuration screen for
pokemon go on your smart device oh here
it is look we're gonna pair pair my
device oh no I can't even call right now
get out of here it says even on a bear
yes I do got it just vibrated holy moly
when I pokemon is nearby the device
vibrates and blinks green light for
pokemon you've caught yellow light for
pokemon you haven't caught that's the
button to try to catch it after you
press the button you'll see multicolored
lights for success red light for pokemon
that have run away and when you're in
range of a pokey stop the device
vibrates and the light loose blue press
the button to search focus app for items
the light will blink multicolored for
success and shine red for out of range
alright it's paired so everything is
awesome now okay
so now what I'm gonna drop some incense
and hopefully let the lure up okay ah
okay it's flashing blue so did I get him
well I guess that's it this is the
pokemon gold plus there's really not
much that I can do because there's zero
Pokemon around here there's no pokey
stops uh basically I'm gonna need to go
out into the wild and try it out but for
now I'm going to leave you guys with a
really fun pokemon hunt that I did not
too long ago I've been meaning to post
this vlog for awhile but I hadn't had a
chance to edit it yet so I thought hey
what a really great way to end a Pokemon
go Plus unboxing then Polster pokemon go
hunting video where I'm not even using
the pokemons go plus but I will and I
will follow up with any
no thoughts on how it works I feel like
it's almost a little bit too simple for
things to really go well but we'll see
hopefully the Apple watch version will
be out soon so I look forward to showing
you guys that and yeah so here's some
fun problem on hunting hey guys guess
what we're doing today let me give you
one hint so we just kind of met like
what two weeks two weeks from that last
week last week oh that's me oh my
goodness
so everyone was very impressed um with
your pokedex so we were like man before
you move we gotta go hunting first thing
what are you trying to catch oh I
already have one I mean I'm trying to
catch them all I don't know about you
guys but um I don't even know I haven't
seen me see what are we let's let me let
me take a little peek I honestly do just
want jars all right so we need to go we
need to go with harvest yeah so there's
a ton of char matters of the back of the
pier yeah but going towards like Hot Dog
on a Stick in like that area squirrels
and stuff spawn over here a lot there's
a few spawn on Broadway app called
go-go radar yeah yes that's like Golden
Nugget does it fast does it work again
because for a while it did it it's back
up I might need to redownload this then
please hold
and we're people that don't play the
game anymore that's not my problem
that's your problem I still enjoyed him
he said people still play that I said oh
yeah I don't play it as much as I did
before because you know things have
changed the game it's so much harder to
actually trap Pokemon
another get a really you're anything
else like what we did we did nothing
nothing else got accomplished they look
they look like they're hunting so
there's something that we need to blow
it is smudgy you guys are gonna need to
hold on I'm like guys look gross what
are you saying about the pokemons
perfect what yes so there's Pokemon
percentage - perfect they're called IVs
they're individual values so each
Pokemon has a stat of attack defense and
stamina however the game doesn't show us
this stuff hypothetically what would
happen is depending on the pokémon you
catch if it's a certain percentage -
it's perfect which would mean if it's
let's say it's 100% perfect he could go
to its max and CP of its of its level so
basically what you're saying is I've
been playing the game completely wrong
so I just go the highest CP and I'm like
cool evolve is that wrong that's wrong
god I've leased this so many great
Pokemon Oh No
everything I know is alive alright so
here's my here's my fish okay my goal
thing so hit that little CEO says
appraised but they don't say like
exactly what the percentage are but each
certain phrase that they say will give
you like an estimate of where kind of
lies
wait a minute so overall going in a
strong Pokemon you should be proud so I
believe it's anywhere between like 60
and 80
so it's an okay Pokemon hmm
so do I my almost art was the biggest
she's ever seen I think she's lying to
me
yeah she says everyone home yeah she
does are you on Balor - yeah what'd he
try to catch actually so it was the
other fish that I was trying to catch
the Magikarp I I still need I need it I
mean my gosh I have a beard I got about
communion because you have to catch a
hundred and one of them
to involve it so I have 155 candy your
teen Valley you have the one you want is
where it says overall your Pokemon
simply amazes me that means if you know
from 81 percent to 100% so you want it
to say that
let's appraise my Magikarp appraise hey
Justine let's take a look at your
magical shall we strong you should be
proud
HP strongest feature boom impress with
this attack it's got excellent stats how
exciting what's wrong what could this
insult yeah guys so tiny
yeah okay work we're hatching oh I just
hatched a Magikarp so we're trying to
hunt oh my gosh she just popped up he
just bought them could you hold this
real quickly sorry again oh gosh oh wait
oh boy he's keep swatting my balls yes
Shia praise it yes okay
my Dewgong okay back with honey this is
so exciting what a great day
[Music]
we're now moving on we all caught a do
dong to come honestly
Jenna was just talking about how you
know before this came out she didn't
know anything about Pokemon I'm sorry
you know I just started playing and I
think it's really fun and I think when
Pokemon Sun and Moon comes out and
that's gonna be my first kind of like
taste of a real Pokemon game is that a
good idea yeah I'm so excited about that
you don't have a squirrel okay I think I
do
wait maybe I don't I don't think I have
a squirtle we're gonna find out I don't
think I do
hi ru thank you I just got a squirrel
does your squirtle may not be great in
battle but I still like it
its defenses its strongest feature its
best indicates it in battle it'll get
the job done hope I was able to help
take care and I finally found some shade
so I want you guys to check out all of
your amazing people I mean basically
have everything um yeah I mean kind of
so this is my pokedex 141 and the one
that I need right now is muck I can't
find any grime errs anywhere and then
the other ones like 83 I believe is
far-fetched one of these two are
kangaskhan and mr. mime and then ditto
still not in the game so I just need one
for the u.s. pokedex with your highest
EP um it's one of my dragon eyes 2364
one of them yeah I caught I caught three
of them here and then I evolved two of
them one day guys one day out of there
one day when I get my Pokemon Gold Plus
oh that's the the little job thing I
don't know so I have this crazy thought
and it was really scary if I drop my
camera in here at home what would I do
what I jump in to get it but then I
realize I can't swim
and if I were to jump into here far far
no I know
and then I thought well if I did jump in
and I couldn't actually this camera then
I have to swim to find somewhere to save
myself and I don't know where I'd go so
The Drowsy is a
anteater whose chocolate-dipped that's
what he is chocolate dipped anteater
guys there's a gas leak gastly spotted
alright guys so that was our fun little
peer pokey hunting
I hope wait a lovely time I got two
things today what I got a squirtle that
I didn't have na Dougal dude I was about
to say do dong I don't remember
whatever I called it before like I've
probably seen him on the pier before
like when we first came down here
because I used to see people vlogging
and I'd like to mind unlike their
vlogging and like wait
so my there's a high probability yeah
cuz I haven't here off so much too much
ah so much fun well thank you so much
for hunting yeah thanks for having me
make sure you go check out your team
it's app absolutely Zack hey yeah it's
yeah exactly
yeah I went now slaughter some your
videos Oh like this is great my best
friends like he always calls me Aptech
he's like your app tech like shut up I
was called you that he's moving to
Australia so you can get the whole
Australian Pokemon that's why I think
truthfully it is yeah I knew the game
was coming out a year ago and I was like
guys going Australia well thank you so
much for watching let me know what your
highest Pokemon is in your decks I don't
even know you were telling about the IV
and stuff and it's just it's a lot it's
a lot so I'll take it later please our
beautiful jet black 256 gig iPhone
I am already smudging this up and I'm
not even touching the actual phone yet I
don't think I can see that but I haven't
even taken off the safety paper yet
safety paper that's what we're gonna
call it